[Music]
all right people today is a big day
we've got some announcements and some
major stuff cooking this is basically
going to be a live stream that will
culminate a year of my life that I
haven't really been talking about that
I've been kind of teasing about for the
last year but on top of doing this show
and touring and going to colleges and
stand-up and writing a book somehow I
managed to squeeze that in in the last
year too
I also started a tech company it was
about a year ago right now basically
this very week and I'll get to why it
was this week started a tech company to
solve as many of the problems that are
humanly possible that we all know are
sort of the biggest problems of the day
and I'm not talking about our political
problems and I'm not talking about our
cultural problems and our social
problems except I'm talking about all of
them at the exact same time we all know
there are massive problems with big tech
you are watching this on YouTube right
now I hope this went to your feed but
there's a good chance that it didn't go
to your feed we have something like 1.2
million subscribers and I think we give
YouTube a pretty professional show that
could be on network television right I
mean we've we've built something here
that's pretty spectacular and we've got
a great crew and a great studio and and
really expensive lights and all that
good stuff and we put out a weekly show
sometimes more than once a week here on
YouTube but we have no access really to
our own subscribers our own fans now we
all know that the algorithms are
manipulated in really weird ways they
can decide what videos to push to you in
your recommended videos it's just a
calve acade of problems related to how
you actually get the content that
creators are creating and this is not
just my problem this is a problem for
quite literally millions and millions of
other creators and by the way it's not
just YouTube that has these problems we
everyone knows at this point that
Twitter shadow bans people and you just
go
sometimes months without seeing people
in your feed I see it in my feet all the
time I get people messaging me every day
and I'm not talking about furries or
anime avatars or eggs I'm talk about
real people who say you know I just
never see you in in Twitter anymore we
know that that there's Dee boosting and
down ranking all of these big tech words
that basically are meant to manipulate
what information you can get how you can
get it when you can get it if you can
get it all of those things and a lot of
really bright people have been trying to
solve as many of these problems as
possible so about a year ago
that's where I decided to really get
more involved into this game I'm gonna
get to that in just a sec but first let
me just tell you a couple things that
we're gonna do throughout this so what
I've decided to do was well you know
we'll do this a little bit differently
well I'll tell you the story first and
then well then we'll tease out some
stuff here so a year ago right about now
I was still funding this show on patreon
I'm sure many of you remember about a
year before that I had had jack conte
who is the CEO of patreon I had had him
in here in this very studio after they
had booted some people off of patreon
off of the platform I think it was
specifically it was lauren southern that
they had booted off the platform and
Jack basically made all these assurances
that you know people will be safe on
patreon and it's not what you say on off
their platform it's what you say on
their platform and lauren had broke some
sort of Amorphis rule that they had
doesn't matter it's their platform you
guys know my policy on these companies
can do whatever they want to do that's
fine with me but I had Jack in here and
he said he announced a new phrase
actually during our interview he said
that they would respond to and you could
be banned for manifests observable
behavior which is a fantastic acronym
mob manifest em observable Oh behavior B
so mob behavior is what could get you
booted off patreon time in you can't
make this up right so anyway so I
had him on
I think his answers weren't weren't
really totally sadist
but I treated the guy with the same
respect that I treat everybody else and
then about a year goes by I I already
was feeling ah I don't know how much
longer I can stay on patreon because
they can always come up with some reason
to boot you any of these platforms can
always come up with any reason to boot
anybody as you guys may know just last
week and II know who is a journalist a
real journalist not a journalist that I
have to put quotes around he's an actual
journalist he was suspended from Twitter
because he made a factual comment about
race related to people that are
attacking trans people he made a factual
comment and Twitter decided you're gonna
be suspended for that he eventually
deleted it after a couple days so
they're not in in the game of truth now
again these companies can do what they
want and you guys know my feeling I
don't want the government involved right
I mean you all saw just a couple weeks
ago
AOC and the rest of them grilling Mark
Zuckerberg on Capitol Hill and it's like
do I want big tech and now the
government to be even more intertwined
so that the government can tell big tech
what to do and I know some of the Trump
people right now actually kind of want
that right but it's like well Trump may
not be president in a year or two and
then you've given over the power to
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders or
something anyway we're still talking
about a lot of high-level stuff here so
a year ago you may remember this sargon
of akkad Karl Benjamin who I've had on
this show
he was booted off patreon because he
said the n-word
although he was mocking the alt-right
use of the n-word but he said the n-word
not on patreon which he was a he was a
patron but he was a creator on patreon
it wasn't on patreon it wasn't even on
his YouTube channel that he was funding
through patreon it was on some third
channel and again he was using the word
to basically mock be all right he wasn't
saying it as as a pejorative shortly
after he was basically immediately
booted from patreon and there was sort
of no recourse and then I'm sure many of
you guys remember over the next couple
weeks a few high-level people myself
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris
we all left patreon and started funding
on our own and what I found was actually
pretty amazing and then this is where my
decision to start a company which I'm
about to get to all began on January
15th of this current year we officially
closed my patreon account for weeks I
had been telling people leave patreon
join us at Dave Rubin calm we built out
a great site so that we could just do
the same fan funding that we were doing
on patreon we actually went to a place
where we were offering no reward so on
patreon I was doing all these Google
Hangouts and we were sending people all
this stuff and it was becoming another
job unto itself and we then just created
Dave Rubin calm and we allowed people to
just donate whatever they wanted to do
to help us keep the show independent
everything else and we found that by not
even giving rewards just showing a
little bravery just kind of sticking up
against against big tech against patreon
in this case that our revenue actually
jumped about 30% so we were actually
giving people less rewards in that we
were giving them no rewards anymore and
our revenue jumped because people were
like oh Dave and Jordan and Sam and and
a few other people it's like oh you guys
are doing something good and doing
something brave in a really bizarre time
so as we decided to do that I thought
this isn't enough you know I because of
a couple years of doing this have built
a nice a nice business here and I've got
a great staff and we were able to build
us a website and figure out how to fan
fund and my my garage I'm in my garage
right now my my studio is in my home my
my control room right over there is a
guest bedroom and the green room right
over there is another guest bedroom
we've built an incredible business here
and what I realized was I want to start
giving the tools that I've been able to
build I want to start giving them to
other creators because these problems
are not going away and it doesn't matter
if you're on the left or if you're on
the right or if you're even a politics
creator you could be a knitter or a
gamer or a chef or quite literally a nun
boxer that's a thing apparently you
could be anyone online and you have no
idea about how you can create a
functional business when the big tech
overlords can either silence you or just
push you to the side altogether or deep
boost you or shadow ban you or the rest
of it okay so now I'm going to do the
first call to action of the day so what
did I do and I'll explain all about it
in a little bit over the past couple
would spend about two months we have
done a soft launch for the Rubin report
community app and what I believe is and
it's consistent with everything else
that I talk about on this show is that
the internet is about to flip that we've
done everything sort of top-down right
we have big tech companies telling
everyone what to do and how to behave
and all of those things all the time and
we have no recourse
you know you get suspended you don't
know how to contact them for years I had
no contact at YouTube despite giving
them a pretty a pretty damn good show if
I do say so myself we finally do have a
contact there now but you have no
recourse with these companies they don't
really care if you're if you're there or
you're not there they you know they want
all your data and all of that stuff and
I thought I want to give some of these
tools back so we created the Rubin
report app which right now by the way
we've not I've never announced it until
just now we've had a small beta launch
and then we sent out an email to a
couple people you can now get the Rubin
report app in the App Store and in
Google Play there's also a desktop
version of it if you go to Rubin report
com
and what I believe is that small
communities are now going to be the
future of the Internet that what we have
to start doing is giving the power back
to creators it's like every time you
sign on Twitter or even you go on your
feet and YouTube however they've
manipulated it it's like all of these
things are making us all crazy you start
aiding people you liked you're fighting
with trolls and BOTS and all of these
things all of these people have a
million burner fake accounts you're
seeing the the blue check Twitterati or
treated a certain way and can say
certain things that other people can't
say we watch accounts get banned all the
time as they kind of clear out the brush
so what I thought is what we need to do
is that creators again whether they
agree with me politically or not whether
they're in the political space or not
need to start being able to own all of
their properties own their video be able
to directly communicate with their fans
have their fans be able to communicate
with each other make sure you can have
ad free video and AD free podcast and
you can communicate directly with me
this case in my app but with with the
whatever creator you're supporting so we
built the app it's been about two months
now it's it's huh mannan and her and and
and I'm very impressed with what we
built here and people have really been
digging it and here's part of it now and
then I'll get to the wider the wider
business proposition its
subscription-based I actually think that
part of the problem right now is that
because everything is free online you
become the product your your data your
information you can make all these
million fake accounts all of these
things and I watch it's funny I'll see
this on Twitter all the time
I'll watch really bright people like
well-known authors and lecturers
thinkers people who I've had on the show
who I totally respect I'll watch them on
Twitter and they're fighting with pink
foxes and they're fighting with street
fighter characters on Twitter anonymous
ones and what I think is we need a
maturing of the Internet and I think
that small gated communities that then
figure out how to network with each
other and I'm gonna get to that in a
little bit are gonna be the future of
the Internet it's not that Twitter won't
exist it's not that YouTube won't exist
it's not that Facebook won't exist but I
think people are gonna have to show a
little bit of skin in the game to start
being involved in communities where
there's actual mature conversation and
one of the things that we've we've built
with this app and I'm going to talk
about locals calm which is the company
we started in just a sec is that on
YouTube right now as I said I have about
1.2 million subscribers I have no way of
communicating with these people because
when we put a video out for example this
live stream right now we have no idea
how many people that actually subscribe
and click the bell and the whole thing
we have no many people get this video
when we put up any video any clip any
full episode it doesn't go out to all of
our people we know that it's going out
to seemingly smaller and smaller amounts
of people so we wanted to create
something where if you as a creator post
something not only do you own it but
it's actually gonna go out to all of
your subscribers we're not going to
manipulate algorithms we're not gonna do
stand-down rank and Shadowman and the
rest of it and here's another beautiful
thing by having a subscription-based
platform
you eliminate 99% of all of the evil
that's online because guess what trolls
generally won't pay you to troll you
right so if you go to rubin report comm
right now on the desktop you can sign up
to be in our community and watch ad free
videos and why listen to the ad free
podcast and communicate with me and with
other fans and all sorts of stuff and
check the feed and you can post
information and buy tickets to events
and all of those things
trolls generally won't pay you but what
I what I believe will happen is by hat
by forcing people to put a little bit of
skin in the game and you can pay
whatever you want it's $3.00 if you want
to pay three dollars it's fifty bucks if
you want to pay fifty bucks if you want
to support more it's totally up to you
but by having a little bit of a skin in
the game we can start building
communities that will be a little bit
more mature than everything else that's
happening everywhere else and then what
we're gonna do is figure out ways to
link these communities to each other so
that all creators are in effect creating
their own network so okay so let me
fast-forward a little bit here so as of
today right now it is open as of this
morning we have started locals calm this
is a company that I created along with
my business partner we brought in three
investors we do not have any big tech
money no big tech money I know some big
tech people but we don't have any of
their money that was Barry I just might
I just went into Trump mode there for a
second
we have three investors who are all fans
this is a beautiful thing you know over
the last couple years I always talk to
you guys about how I've met so many
freaking incredible people who have
offered to work for us who have offered
to volunteer for us intern for us who
have offered to invest in things if the
right thing ever came around
well three people actually did just that
and we got three investors who are fans
of the show who believe in solving
problems outside of big tech and outside
of government right I'm not asking the
government to solve my problems and I'm
not asking big tech to solve my problems
I'm solving my problems myself and
that's what I thought is if I can solve
all of my problems as a creator right I
am I am as independent as anyone that
you could watch in this space right not
only do I do this show from home
we're fan funded we're totally free to
make every decision for good or bad all
the decisions ultimately fall on me and
what I wanted to do was give some of
that ability to some other people one of
the one of the days that this really hit
me was about a year ago also when tucker
carlson walked into my garage and he's
about to do the show we're like five
minutes from going live and he walks in
he opens the door he sees the studio and
he goes holy man you have done it
right and it's like this guy is I think
the highest-paid person on cable news
and he walked into my garage and sees
Wow here's this guy that built it
himself he's free and it's pretty damn
good so that's why we started locals
calm and here's what we're gonna do what
I want is we are gonna build
subscription-based communities for all
kinds of creators again even if you hate
me if you're one of the people watching
this and you hate me and I'm sure you're
out there we if you have any sort of fan
base and you are creating anything
worthwhile we want to work with you we
want to work with you you can jump on
locals calm right now and sign up we're
gonna be selecting creators we already
have a couple pretty big-name people
actually that have signed on already who
were gonna unveil over the next couple
weeks and months so here's the another
beautiful thing about your community so
when you create your community and again
you can put video on there add free
video we've got a beautiful video player
and add free podcast and you can
communicate with your fans and all of
those things and a great feed and all
that you will find like-minded creators
that you want to link with on the back
end and if they agree to link with you
and you to agree to link with them you
can actually create your feeds together
thus basically creating a network effect
we've actually got a pretty cool
referral program I don't want to get too
lost in that right now and you will
create a network and not only that but
here's here's the real thing that's
that's different than everything else
that you're seeing online right now one
of the problems is that we all know that
these big tech companies and it's almost
not their fault it's just the design of
when these things become these sort of
monstrous behemoths we know that the
Terms of Service can never be upheld
properly right it's it's just there's so
many freaking competing interests and
political interests and all of these
things so
like you sign on to Twitter and you've
got white nationalist frogs arguing with
you know crazy socialists and anarchists
and all of these people and everyone's
trying to ban everybody and all that
when you create your community with
locals calm you set your rules so in my
community I've set a very very what I
would say are open-ended set of rules
that basically as long as well you're
not breaking the laws of the United
States and you're not being just an
awful relentless sort of schmucky troll
you can be in our community and you can
keep it respectful and hang out and talk
in all of those things if you if you
can't do that I don't want you in my
community now that is not an
infringement on free speech so I'm gonna
beat you guys to the punch on that one
free speech I absolutely believe in free
speech but this is why I wanted to
create small communities not a giant
platform a giant platform when they
silenced people or they ban people that
you can definitely argue and many people
have done it in the studio is an actual
infringement on free speech because big
tech has become the way we all
communicate with each other when you do
something with small communities it's
like you know I'm all for free speech
everyone can say basically whatever they
want you know we have very strict libel
and slander laws and you know you can't
directly threaten to murder somebody
that sort of thing but I don't welcome
everybody into my house all the time to
say whatever they want and what I want
to do with locals calm and this is what
we've done with the Rubin report
community and with the app is we are
gonna build communities where the
creators can set whatever rules they
want so if some creators want very
strict rules around around speech and
what can and can't be said on the type
of people they want in there and all
that that'll be on them and if some
people will have a very liberal open
sense of what they want to do that'll be
on them so again I think that starting
at the bottom down building communities
where the creators themselves are
setting the rules the creators can
figure out who they want to network with
and with all of the ability to actually
communicate with your audience without
having to deal with algorithms and
shadow banning and the rest of it I
think this is actually what the future
of the internet will be I think this
will sort of be internet 3.0 I said
2.0 yesterday on Twitter and a lot of
people took me to task on that but I
really do think that the day of a
gajillion burner accounts and anonymous
accounts and all of that you gotta have
a little skin in the game if you want to
be part of sort of more mature
conversations and by the way not only I
mentioned how how our investors here are
not only fans but people that I've
gotten to know over the last couple
years the amount of other people that
I'm now working with like I think
there's a way we need a community back
when you when you're on Twitter do you
feel like you're getting any sense of
community do you feel better when you're
on Twitter or do you feel worse I'm
guessing that when you sign on Twitter
you go oh why am I doing this again yet
we all keep doing it
when you go on Facebook you end up
looking at your feet and you start
hating people that you're either related
to you're supposed to like that are
supposed to be your friends we we all
walked into this this is nobody's fault
by the way I think there are well there
is actually a lot of evidence that a lot
of these companies design these things
to keep us as addicted as possible but
also you know none of us had this thing
20 years ago right and now we're walking
around the world in our pocket and we
were handed over this awesome power but
you know with great power comes great
responsibility Thank You Uncle Ben and
because of that we've all walked into
these things and now we're sort of
trapped in them and I want to figure out
what an off-ramp is not only for
creators but for people that want to fix
some of this that don't want to be part
of the endless destruction of everything
so here's what I'm gonna do first off
right now I'm gonna do a QA but we're
only doing it for Rubin report community
members so you can go on the Apple App
Store right now or on Google Play or you
can go to Rubin report calm you can
subscribe for as little as $3 and I'm
gonna take questions from people happy
to answer all your questions about big
tech why we did this literally anything
that comes up that is fine and then and
then I want to tell you a little bit
more about sort of what we're building
here and everything else but locals calm
if you're a creator if you are a creator
people and I know you're out there and
you might be a progressive who hates me
and you might be an unboxer or a video
gamer if you want direct access to your
fans there's no reason to be on patreon
why are you on a platform that could
boot you at any moment that really
doesn't offer you anything other than
they make sure you get paid
well we're gonna make sure you get paid
every month you will be paid every month
we take the exact same fee as patreon
but we're gonna build you a desktop
community and for the creators that are
of a higher level sort of we're on that
but not not doesn't have to all be there
we'll build you a freakin custom app a
white labelled app as well so there's a
there's a real beauty to what we're
building here you will secure your
assets you will make sure you don't own
the stuff that you put on YouTube if
YouTube boots me now we have backups
here right I've got a server with
backups and we've got a lot of hard
drives with backups but you're gonna own
your data on locals calm yeah it's your
dad atone and by the way if you leave
locals if I was to leave YouTube right
now the 1.2 million people that we have
subscribing this I have no way of
telling them where I'm going I have no
way of getting a message out to them
yeah I can put it in the feed but we
know that that doesn't go anywhere
if you leave locals calm congratulations
you get all their email addresses and
the rest of it all of the data that you
have provided us with is yours we're not
going to be in the business of selling
data either we're trying as hard as we
can to solve as many of the problems
that are humanly possible and and that's
that's what the plan is and that's what
we're gonna do so okay I had a question
about the community name part of signing
up for locals that does that refer to
your individual endeavors or your
industry or possibly either or both so
right now if you go to locals comm we
have an open sign up right now look and
we're also looking to scale the business
and we're trying to find more investors
in the rest of it so this isn't all
gonna happen overnight we've brought on
a couple of people and our team is
growing we've got we actually got an
incredible team oh and I should say by
the way I am not taking a dime from this
company I am not on salary I've put
money into the company and I've put a
tremendous amount of time into the
company and I obviously own a portion of
the company but I'm not taking any money
from the company I'm not on salary or
anything like that this is I believe in
this thing I'm taking a risk right like
everybody complains all the time like
everybody complains about Oh Twitter do
this and YouTube do this and I do it too
right and then the other people say
government get involved government do
this this is my best effort shot to see
if we can fix some of this stuff and and
really look at the Internet in a whole
new way stop thinking big tech and the
goliaths are our man
but focus a little bit more on small
communities and and look if David beat
Goliath well I think Dave can maybe beat
Google we shall see anyway the answer to
your question is when you're signing up
give us the name of what you want your
community to be all of these things can
change over time and we're just trying
we're just actually right now by
launching locals calm today pretty great
name - how do we get locals calm not bad
right
because you're creating your local
that's the idea I this is so consistent
with all the things that I talked about
about small government and why you want
to care more about your local community
than the big hegemonic monster that is
somewhere far far away right I want you
whoever you are and by the way these
this doesn't even have to be purely
YouTube creators or podcasters or things
like that if you run a local baseball
league and you want a community a
web-based community and potentially an
app for your community so they can all
contact each other and you can contact
them and you're not doing it on Facebook
and you're not doing it on Twitter and
it's a good way to fundraise for your
community then we want you to be part of
it so there's so many cool applications
for this that I'm very excited about
that so also we should remember most of
the people that are going to do this
that are gonna join us on local is calm
you're gonna be established creators so
obviously we're not creating communities
for if you've got two people willing to
pay you well we can't really go into
business with you but as I say to people
all the time who are always telling me
Dave I want to do what you do I want to
be a youtuber I want to be a podcaster I
want to get into the political space
it's like keep building your stuff and
once you have enough people that are
supporting you that you have a
worthwhile community well then locals
com will build you your community and
again remember how cool it is the idea
that you're going to set your rules and
then on the back end so I don't want to
announce I'll announce at least one next
week but we've got some great creators
on board already and when we connect
these communities on the backend where
the creator one creator another creator
will have to say we want our communities
you know we have we have a similar ethos
something like that right and we want
our communities to be together on the
back end within the
feed you'll be able to see more and more
creators so we're giving creators the
power to create networks too so there's
there's a lot of cool stuff here all
right let's see the minimum monthly
contribution from supporters won't go
below $2 as a smaller content creator
with a modest following what if I'd like
to make my content free in order to
build a following will that be possible
so right now with a way we're doing it
at Rubin report calm is our minimum is
three dollars I want people to have a
little bit of skin in the game it's not
much many people do more than that
because they just want to support
ultimately if you create your own local
and you're a creator you can do whatever
minimum you want you can do whatever
maximum or no maximum you want that'll
be completely up to you and we have
several ways that we can work with
creators some you know for some people
that are only going to bring in a tiny
bit of revenue at the beginning you're
gonna have to you know pay a little
something upfront so that we can build
you this stuff I mean these are all the
ways that a sort of mature business has
to operate but I also want to say this
I'm leaving all of my con everything
that I've been doing on Twitter on
Facebook on Instagram on YouTube the
audio podcast that's all gonna be there
that's all gonna be there now the thing
is I don't own any of those properties
so I don't know when any of those things
could be cut off you don't know it
either everyone sitting there putting
complaining about all of these things
and watching like you know the axe
slowly drop on our necks and the time
now the time basically is now to own
some of this stuff back so again you
will own everything so it's a way of
protecting a lot of your digital assets
too but what you want to charge what
your minimum is what your maximum is the
rest of it is is absolutely completely
up to you how should I go about getting
started on locals calm you can go if
you're a creator you can go to locals
calm right now we have a couple
questions for you and then over the next
couple weeks our team will reach out to
you we're launching a couple people in
the next few weeks and we have to figure
out how we could scale this thing
properly and we don't want to over
promise write everybody over promises
all the time but if you have a fanbase
if you have some subscribers if you're
on patreon right now and you're just
sick of they're not offering you
anything right like patreon is a it's a
big tech company
that basically there's no community
there like you post things and a couple
people comment what we're trying to do
is I truly truly truly believe that the
next version of the Internet is cleaning
up the endless mess that we're all in
all the time we're all fighting all the
time you see something on Twitter from
somebody that you didn't know halfway
across the world who said something you
didn't like and then everyone's
destroying each other
I actually think and this is I know this
is happening right now because when I
open the Reuben Report app right now
it's like when I open Twitter it's like
uh what's going on on Twitter now when I
open the Reuben report comm app we've
got really cool people in there with
thoughtful interesting questions and
comments and you know we can if you do a
feed you can just see a feed that's just
what I'm posting and what the Reuben
report is posting or you can do a feed
where it's fans that are posting as well
and people are communicating with each
other and again by literally charging
just three bucks or having a little bit
of a gated community not an armed gated
community with people outside with
rifles shooting the zombies as they
cross over but just having a little skin
in the game
trolls won't pay it to Petrolia and if
they want to either
I guess I'll gladly take your money or
if you're just being a relentless
which is sort of how we everyone
behaves especially Anonymous in the
online what were fund your money I just
don't want you in my community but any
creator can set whatever rules they want
about that so that's that's pretty great
so we're excited about that from Mike
thank you for spending the time money
and effort I'm all signed up and ready
to go awesome look I thought everyone's
trying to solve every problem and
everyone's trying to outsource their
problems and it's like when I was
watching that that thing on Capitol Hill
and these politicians who have never
done anything they've never accomplished
anything they're grilling Mark
Zuckerberg now I have no love for him
necessarily but it was like they're
grilling Mark Zuckerberg about how he
has to be the one to decide what truth
is online and they're gonna punish him
if he doesn't figure it out it's like
you guys are trying to outsource your
jobs to him they the government knows
that they can't infringe on your First
Amendment your your right to free speech
so they're trying to force Facebook to
do it no more of this this this is
childish
since and we need some adults in the
room again and I think there's a great
opportunity here to start while they're
all fighting about all that nonsense
let's find let's find good creators who
are doing interesting things let's make
sure that they can monetize properly
right if you're a creator on YouTube
right now and you're and you're not
doing any sort of subscription thing you
have no idea what your read is we look
at our reverie month and depending on
whether YouTube's decided to let us see
the videos let the audience see the
videos or not or what gets monetized or
D monetize or whatever our revenues like
this try to build a business like that
that's why when we started doing fan
funding which now we originally got on
patreon gosh that was in I think May of
2015 if I'm not mistaken so we've been
doing this for over three years so I
think I'm one of the people that have
been the sort of at the front end of
what creators are trying to do and as I
said because we built this and we're
totally independent I sort of think that
I'm the right guy to help us get out of
this mess I want to give all of the
tools that have helped me be independent
I want to give them to as many creators
as possible and and I think that really
is what the future of the Internet is
that's what I'm excited about oh oh you
know here's what we're gonna do we got
some new promo shots right here okay
professional promo shots people so any
for the first hundred people that sign
up at Rubin report com or download the
app in the in the Apple App Store or in
Google Play I'm gonna sign one of these
for you today and we're gonna mail them
out and you have to do $10 or more and
you are gonna get a dave rubin signed
promo shot from this live stream there's
the first one right there
you know sign-in pictures you know sign
of pictures kissing babies it's like run
and it's like running for president
people okay from Jonathan Dave what an
awesome app this is you should be very
proud of your work this is amazing cool
I'm really I mean for those of you so
right now by the way if you go to the
Apple App Store and you download the
Reuben report app or if you go to Google
Play and download it you can download it
for free but you can't interact with any
of the content so if you just if you're
just
going what the they Dave create
here is this all nonsense and blah blah
blah go look at the app you won't be
able to comment you won't be able to
communicate with other people or with me
but you will see we have a freaking
slick video player the ad-free podcast
is in there ultimately we don't have it
yet but we're working on it we'll have
it probably in just a matter of weeks
we're gonna have group chat so I'll be
able to just you know so I'm sitting at
the airport I can just open up a group
chat you'll get a push notification on
your phone and dozens of people will be
in there chatting we're gonna have one
on one messenger as I said you can buy
tickets to events all of these things
and there's no middleman and this is
what I wanted to create for everybody
else that's a creator out there no more
middleman if you've got some fans if
you've got some base of support then we
want you to have all of the technology
which we own all of it we built all of
this from from scratch from the bottom
up nobody owns a piece of this thing
besides us okay we wanted to give you
guys all of the tools so you could
communicate with your fans all the time
so if you're if you're a youtuber right
now think about it you could be a
massive YouTube let's think about the
biggest youtuber roll PewDiePie right so
PewDiePie's got four hundred billion
subscribers or whatever it is YouTube
could shut him down today he would have
no ability to get to those people right
now I'm not saying they are gonna do it
I'm not saying that everyone in big tech
is evil I'm not even saying there's some
mass conspiracy here but shouldn't we as
creators whatever it is you're doing
again even if you hate all of the things
that I'm doing with this show shouldn't
creators be able to make sure that they
can get in contact with the people that
support them and do it outside of an
old-school email list I mean that people
have been basically reduced to email
lists and creating group chats on
whatsapp with their fans like that's
that's not right that's not cool it's
not good so we want to give all of those
tools back to you and have you set
whatever rules you want in your
community you can do whatever you want
we're not trying to create some Terms of
Service that is going to fit everybody
all the time we have a basic Terms of
Service of you know you can't put you
know illegal things on their snuff
videos there's you know things like that
but basically you create whatever you
want create whatever you want and if you
have fans that are willing to pay you
for it you can communicate with
however you want to okay let's see
hi Dave I'm producing a musical with a
friend about one of the books on the
Bible we've been shut down twice and got
reported many times now by trolls who
don't like our show my question is is
locals com gonna be our new house to
sell tickets merchants connect with our
audience yes absolutely we will build
you a community go to Reuben report calm
right now just sign in and create an
account and sign in and you can see the
exact community that we will build for
you and we are going to add new features
to it and live streaming and a whole
bunch of other stuff but yes if you I
mean that's a great example like you
might be in a theater group you might be
a band whatever it is that you're
creating if you want to have a rich
experience with your fans with your
community and then figure out so let's
say you're doing a musical about the
Bible okay let's say there are five
other people out there creators that are
creating similar similar kind of things
maybe not exactly the same maybe I like
some of them you don't like them but
let's say now they have their own locals
so your local is what we created for you
it's whatever your website is so mine's
Reuben report com you've got your whole
community there now you find some other
groups that are that are kind of doing
similar things and you want to expand
what your fan base is you want to find
have the ability for new people to find
you and you want to find new people and
you want to connect have a network
effect with other creators right well
they'll be on locals too and then you
can combine on the backend so your feed
is one thing so it's not like on Twitter
it's like okay you see a politics tweet
a baby picture a terrorist it's like
it's not right for the brain it's all
it's all making us all crazy
so yes you absolutely will be able to
create your own community and have the
people who want to support you you'll be
able to make sure that you don't lose
touch with them just because the big
tech overlords are stopping you from
doing it oh by the way you know I said
10 bucks for the further you sign
pictures right here so if you go to
Reuben report com
it's 10 you know for 10 you can sign up
for as little as 3 but for 10 dollars
we're gonna get these out to you today
because you're gonna put your email
address in we'll contact you get your
address we're gonna mail these out to
you but on the app itself just because
there's some rules
with the Apple AppStore its $9.99 to
sign up there so if you do if you do
sign up directly through the app through
the Apple App Store it's $9.99 we will
send you the signed the signed picture
right there okay let's see from Morgan
I've been creating some content for what
I thought this would be but it's not
quite ready yet is there a timeframe
where my community name will be shut
down for a lack of activity that's a
great question we did discuss something
like that in the last couple days I
would say for now go ahead and sign up
if you're thinking about it or let's say
let's say you're one of the type of
people that I get questions from all the
time especially at colleges I want to be
a creator I want to be a youtuber I want
to be a podcaster you may as well sign
up right now locals calm and I don't
know how long we can just hold every
name if you're not gonna build your
community in some sort of timely fashion
but for now you may as well sign up and
then and then we'll deal with it there
those are that that's what I'm talking
about about not solving all the problems
all at once and not over promising if
you if you think there's a chance that
that you want to be part of this that
you want to be able to have your own
community so people can always contact
you that hopefully if you're a big
enough creator and then we can build you
a pretty freakin sleek custom white
labeled app like we've got for me right
now then you may as well sign up and I
don't know how long we can hold
everything for so so we'll see that's
actually a great question oh I'm gonna
sign a couple so people are actually
giving us their names at the moment so I
want to thank Nick Kristina Jessica and
Rick who have all just signed up at
Rubin report.com is it okay to have
paying sponsors for communitychannel
okay this is a great question so look I
actually believe that part of the
problem right now is that the
advertising mess on YouTube especially
is what caused so much of this problem
right so if like anybody says anything
that's that's out of off the Overton
Window or just a little politically
incorrect then the mob comes and it's
usually not even people who were
supporting the creator in the first
place it's just like you know the media
matters HuffPo box by box
BuzzFeed Vox it's like they gin
all of this hate to make sure that
Tucker gets taken off or that Ben
Shapiro's podcast sponsors dump him or
whatever it is and that that is
unfortunately one of the risks that's
coming with advertisers now I want to be
extremely clear so our our podcast right
now our audio podcast we've never been
boycotted by a sponsor I've had people
try to get my sponsors to quit our
sponsors have been great and that is a
piece of our business right so so our
business basically has sort of three
prongs and again these are some of the
lessons that I want to show younger
creators or newer creators how to create
a successful business that's why we
created locals it's like we've done
something really cool here people tell
me about it all day long every day I'm
incredibly proud of what we've built
here so we've created a business where
our subscription model and again we were
not giving anyone anything after we left
patreon it was just because you wanted
to support what we were doing here
make sure I can pay my guys a decent
salary we pay all their health insurance
and all that good stuff that's about 70%
of our read then we have audio podcasts
Reb which is ads on the audio podcast
and then we have the YouTube Reb which I
say as I said it's like this you just
kind of can't you can't sort of it's not
a way that you can look at a functional
business and go okay we can project this
for next month and this for six months
down the road because you just don't
know if it's going to be there on top of
the fact that you don't know that people
are even going to see your videos so the
question is are we going to allow
sponsorships in there it's something
we're discussing it's a it's a little
bit different than the model obviously
that I'm talking about right now because
what I really want is I want you person
watching this right now I know you guys
don't mind paying a little something for
content right everyone pays for Netflix
or you'd have your mom's password or
Disney Plus you got your uncles brothers
cousins nephews nieces password whatever
it is I started the mandalorian last
night it was excellent by the way I
believe that subscriptions are the
future because by I think by you putting
in just a couple bucks if that's what
you want to put in or if you really love
a creator and you want to put in more
you put in more but by putting in a
couple bucks I think a it will make
people act a little bit more maturely
right like part of the problem is that
the reason that there are a million
burner accounts and people can sign
a thousand different accounts and you
can have anonymous people trolling
people all day and just raising havoc
like everyone knows everyone knows
something's wrong right now something is
wrong with our level of discourse and a
huge amount of it has to do with just
that there's just all of these bad
actors out there
I actually think through a couple bucks
and I can see this right now in our in
our community
we've got great thoughtful people in
there by the way most of them have their
real picture in their real name how
novel right because it's like oh you
know you're sort of surrounded by
interesting people and I want to give
every creator out there the chance to
have their own sort of home right now
this is what I said before I'm all for
free speech all for free speech I don't
want to infringe on anybody's free
speech but I don't let everyone in my
home to say whatever they want and what
I want creators to have is a stable home
where they can put their content up
where they can communicate with their
fans where their fans can communicate
with them and there is no middleman
there is no middleman we're gonna take
the exact same fee that patreon is
taking so if you're on patreon right now
and you're a creator well wouldn't you
rather your own community and
potentially your own app if you're big
enough so that we financially can make
it work and you own all of the stuff and
if you leave as I said before if you
leave us congratulations you get the the
information of all your customers unlike
YouTube unlike Twitter all of those
things if Twitter boots me today those
700,000 people are however many
followers I have I have no way of
communicating with them same as YouTube
same as the rest of it okay so just a
quick little radio recap here you go to
locals calm we have launched officially
today the first thing that we did with
locals calm was build the Reuben report
community app we want to build these
communities first on desktop then on
apps for as many creators as we possibly
can we then want creators to network
with each other find the type of people
that you want to be associated with and
have free voluntary associations with
other interesting creators set the rules
in your community if you don't want
people talking about X Y & Z you set the
rules big tech isn't going to set the
rules you set the rules monetize your
content properly by support of your own
fans directly and as the question the
previous question was will
look into some ways there might be some
interesting creative ways we can do
sponsorship where maybe sponsors come in
and sponsor X amount of people to get in
for free for a certain amount of time
we're thinking about all sorts of things
so we'll see about that sort of thing
but we started I wanted to solve my
problem first I cannot solve you know
everyone everyone has this idea out
there that we should solve everybody's
problem at once right we've got to solve
everybody's problem ones I don't think
you can solve everybody's problem ones I
thought if we can solve what are the
problems that me as a creator that's
right in the middle of the free-speech
battle that's right in the middle of the
tech battle who somehow in the course of
this managed to graduate to the point
that I actually am truly free well there
was one there was one piece of this that
left me not free and that piece was that
I don't own the access to you guys right
like YouTube right now they're probably
not that thrilled with me right this
very second like they could just end
this stream they could make sure nobody
sees this stream Twitter in the shadow
band all of those things so every
creator should have direct access to
their community so you can create
whatever you want and you can set rules
that you want or have or you don't set
any rules which it's actually up to you
okay let's see as the Rubin report
community grows how will that play into
locals calm will it remain its own
independent community or be integrated
into that what do you see is the future
of the Rubin report community on this
platform so look the idea is small is
the new big the idea is that everyone
every community we're going bottom-up
okay
big tech is top-down right so you got
the big boys you got the Facebook
YouTube Twitter Google etc and they sort
of set the rules and then we're we're
all the way down here it's all of our
data that's that's sort of the lifeblood
for them but this so they're just kind
of sucking from us all the time we're
doing this the other way I want whether
it's whether it's far-left
progressive nutbags if you hate Dave
Rubin but you want to create your own
community and then you have a couple
other content creators who you think
you'd like to network with and you want
to make sure that you're you're also
protected from YouTube and big tech and
all of those things I want you to be on
locals comm so let's say you support a
couple creators on locals calm so let's
say you support me and we bring on
why and Z and you have a couple creators
that you really love you will have a
curated feed of your creators you will
be able to see all of your creators
through through one app through one
community you'll just toggle on who
you're supporting and maybe you don't
want to see some people or maybe you do
want to see other people
that'll be completely up to you and then
one of the things we're deciding right
now is we may ultimately create a locals
comm app that will be sort of the
aggregator app so if you're if you're
the Dave Rubin superfan you'll be able
to access all the creators you support
through our that Reuben report app but
we may have one just locals app wherever
you know it's sort of branded just as
locals and not as you know a specific
creator but either way you'll be able to
get the feed and the content of all of
the people that you support let's see
from Meghan I don't have content I
create our podcast I sell what's the
best way to use the app well if you
don't have content you create or
products to sell well then you probably
well then you're just a consumer of
content right I think that's what you're
saying so you're not creating content
you're not you're not selling a product
right but actually that does bring up an
interesting thing if you were in if
you're just a businessman out there you
you're selling you're selling
supplements you're selling videogames
you're selling electronic equipment
you're selling desks chairs whatever it
is if you've got a little bit of a
community that you want to reach
directly that might be willing to pay a
couple bucks a month to have some sort
of curated information and content from
you guys you should be on here too but
if you don't if you're not a creator of
any kind well then you you won't need a
community yourself but you will be part
of a community or as many communities as
you want to be part of let's see what's
the inspiration for the name locals calm
so it's actually a pretty great story
because look you guys know my feelings
about this like I talked about local all
the time I talk about small government I
talk about those those issues all the
time I talk about just sort of your your
local community is what matters
believe it or not I try to say hello to
my neighbors it's crazy sometimes they
don't want to say hi to me but I try to
so we were trying to figure out a name
so we had it we had an original company
name that still exists but we wanted a
forward-facing name for it for the
and as I mentioned we have three
investors who are great guys who were
fans of the show who all of them
happened to reach out to me to say Dave
you know if you ever build something you
know I've got a little bit of cash let's
let's see if we can make it work so
everyone that is literally everyone who
is involved in this project is a fan of
what we do here is someone that cares
about these ideas like that that's why
I'm so excited about this anyway it
turns out that one of the guys I won't
say his name right now I don't know if
he wants to be named at this very moment
but he actually owned locals calm and we
were sitting there trying to figure out
well what's the forward-facing name of
the company and we're and I'm just
rifling off buzzwords and bah bah bah
bah it's local and it and he was like
well you know I own locals calm and I
thought well I think we have a name so
sometimes things things actually just
work can we get some hints about other
creators coming on board so I don't want
to hint too much right now right because
we've still got things working out but I
have reached out to a couple people we
have a couple big-name people for sure
without question people that are in at
least the world I'm stealing I'm
starting off I'm starting off with my
local community right so I've reached
out to a couple people who I think are
creating good content who are doing it
through fan funding several of them are
on patreon and it's as I said before
it's like there's no need to be on
patreon anymore why why be on patreon
knowing you could be booed at any moment
they don't really offer you much of
anything other than their there your
payment processor but we will be your
payment processor and you will have your
own community and you will own the data
of your customers and if you leave you
can keep that data and we're not gonna
sell your data and a whole bunch of
other stuff and you're setting your
rules etc etc and when you put content
up there you know that your feed is not
going to be manipulated right you know
that your fans when they go on and and
hopefully you know you've subscribed to
a couple people that are on locals
you've got a great curated feed of
people that you're interested in that
are creating great content you know that
the feed itself is not going to be
manipulated because we're not
manipulating the feed the feed is
actually going to be the way that the
feed of Twitter was supposed to be which
is just chronological it'll all be up
there
and because we own all the technology
we're gonna constantly be adding new
features so eventually as I said we're
gonna have live streaming we're gonna
have group chat a whole bunch of other
stuff we're testing out all sorts of
stuff right now we own a hundred percent
of this we are not licensing any of this
stuff we own it and we can we can curate
it and we can we can fine-tune it for
whatever you need as a creator so some
creators may want certain features that
other feed creators don't want we can
build it for you we can build it for you
so if you're curious to as to what we
have built so far you can go to Reuben
report calm and for as little as three
bucks you can be part of the Reuben
report community and you will see what
we are going to build through locals
calm for all kinds of creators it
doesn't matter if you're in the politics
space the sports world video game world
it does not matter if you are creating
anything worthwhile whether that's video
content audio content you've got a great
product to sell whatever it is if you
have any sort of community and you've
got some people that want to support you
and you want to make sure you can
contact them then this is this is how
you can do it okay let's see I signed up
through the Google Play Store at the
$9.99 price can I change my subscription
amount later I'm not creating anything
just looking to participate yes you can
do that yeah you could do that no
problem not a problem at all
let's see you may have gone over this
but is everyone who signs up at locals
com going to have a profile account on
the site or is it something you guys are
going to roll a roll out over time with
waves of people so right now anyone
that's signing up at logo is calm and
from what their messaging me on here
we're getting a ton of signups anyone
who signs up at locals calm we're gonna
have to do a little vetting right so
that's why we ask you a couple questions
about your community are you crowd
funded now etc etc because we obviously
if you've only got three people that are
willing to pay you three bucks we it's
you know just realistically we can't
build your website yet however we do
have some ways where you could pay some
stuff up front so that we can build you
the community and again for the creators
that are of the higher level we're gonna
build you an awesome custom white
labelled app just like I have and I
think you're gonna be pretty freaking
impressed if you haven't done it go to
go to the Apple App Store or Google Play
right now and just check out the app you
don't even have to pay anything to
download it you can just look if you
want you won't be able to engage with
the
content but you can see that we built
something really really cool here so
yeah go ahead sign up and and then we're
gonna we're gonna do some vetting and
we'll figure out if we're able to work
with you and again I don't care what
your political allegiance is I really
don't like this is a business that is
separate from the things that I talk
about here so it could be kind of funny
I'll end up building sort of secure
digital enterprises and communities for
people that probably dislike me but
that's okay that's okay
at least from my end oh I want to thank
a whole bunch of people who have just
signed up for at least $9.99 or for
$9.99 on the app or for $10 or more
you're gonna get assigned we just
printed these babies Dave Rubin headshot
there we go oh not only that one for
those of you that want a a closer look
at Dave Rubin in case you're not sick of
my face yet here you go here I'll sign
that one right now
there we go I'm gonna sign that for the
first name that I see here true it true
it you're getting this one my friend so
I want to thank Truitt lapa throt Alena
wlt Meaghan mysterium Lugosi Martin Matt
Stefon Scott Jeff Jesper luan and
Tristan welcome aboard guys and what we
want you to do is once you're in the
community start posting things that
you're interested in do you do you own a
business let's get some fans to show up
at your businesses I mean that's that
all of this came out of what the last
two years of my life have been which was
touring with Jordan Peterson where every
city I went into I would tweet that were
in the city you know is anything
interesting going on or can I give away
a couple tickets to the show tonight and
I would meet fans in every city and
people that owned restaurants or owned
owned coffee shops or a falafel place
would would take me out and I thought
there's got to be a way to connect these
people with each other but I was at a
restaurant once I think this was in
Seattle I don't want to say the name of
the restaurant and I'll explain why but
the guy invited me and he said when he
invited me he said but do me a favor
don't don't say that you're here because
I'll get a lot of hate for it and I
thought man this is so screwed up the
mob has so scared everybody that someone
who appreciates what I do is inviting me
to their restaurant
knowing that I've got a pretty big
following and if I just tweet it out you
know I'm gonna show up at this
restaurant that they would get business
there is no doubt they would get
business but people are kind of afraid
because of the way the mob operates with
everything and and this was one of the
reasons I thought we could create small
communities that people have to put some
skin in the game well then I think
people are gonna start sharing stuff
more you know I've done this a couple of
times the last few times I've been in
New York City I've tweeted out that I'm
gonna be out in this area tonight right
at like 10 o'clock and then I say I
usually say to people you have to have a
real picture and a real name on Twitter
and if you do I'll DM you and and I've
had people show up and I did one on the
Upper West Side in New York City about
two months ago and and within like 15
minutes about 40 people showed up it was
awesome we had drinks all night I met
great people from every walk of life a
couple of them actually now are our
supporters and I thought this is crazy
that I'm doing this through Twitter but
I can't put up public information on
Twitter because god knows who's gonna
show up in again these there's many
reasons to just create smaller
controlled communities and not infringe
on anyone's free speech if you don't
want to be in this community or you're
gonna you're there to raise hell or just
be an I just don't want you in
there but I'm not deep platforming you
because this isn't a big platform right
that's the way you really have to think
about it these big platforms the REA the
reason they have the be platforming
issue is because these big platforms are
sort of sold to us as if they're for
everybody right everyone can be on there
it's the new way of communicating right
it's like having a phone when phones
first came out 80 years ago right but
the idea that you would do it small
first means it's not really for
everybody you don't invite everyone into
your home you don't go to dinner with
absolutely anybody and everybody all the
time and I think that will be the next
version of the Internet we're gonna have
to curate and be a little more
responsible with who we want to
associate with and then as I said so if
you're a creator right now so a few of
the people that we have that are coming
out and I can't wait to share it with
you I just can't right now but I've
brought on a couple people that I think
you guys dig that are sort of in my
circles and I'm going to connect my app
with their app on the back end so then
we will start having a new type
network with really no overhead because
you're gonna have a whole bunch of
creators who are independent who you
guys can fund as you wish to see funded
who can all set their own rules as they
wish to set and then we will have a
network effect where we will actually be
able to I'll be able to push my fans to
other people that I think are
interesting and hopefully they can do
that to me and I think that's now the
future you know the idea that we need
big networks to get us all sort of get a
bunch of whole wrangle a whole bunch of
cats together just doesn't really make
sense to me I think we can do voluntary
associations with people we like and you
know if if I connect on the backend with
the Creator and then it turns out that
you know he murdered a family of four in
1982 in Wisconsin well then we just
disassociate and that's it
I don't have to if people want to keep
funding him like this is the if the
government has to come for him if the
police haven't come for him for
murdering people well then so be it but
you'll be able to associate who with who
you want to associate with will have
eliminated most of the trolls will
actually make conversation a lot better
I'm very excited about how we can do it
okay let's see you can sign up right now
so just reminder you can sign up right
now at Reuben report.com and you can ask
me anything and you can do it through
the app because we've got an app but
we're gonna build these for the premium
level creators and we're gonna build
desktop communities for smaller creators
and then hopefully you'll become bigger
creators and then we can build you a
great app as well so you can go to
locals calm right now and sign up for
that all right so I've got I've even got
papers here of all the things that I
wanted to hit on and talk to you about
so I thought it would be interesting
actually if I told you just a little bit
but I know some of you know this but
just a little bit about how how my
adventure here sort of led to all of
this so you know I started on YouTube in
February of 2013 with the Young Turks
now I have I have no need to talk
about them or throw them under the bus I
know they do god-awful videos about me
all the time filled with dribble so be
it that's their that's their right on
this very platform of YouTube but I was
with them for about a year and a half
most of you guys know this I was not
thrilled with a lot of the the political
stuff they were doing and
the behavior that they were exhibiting
and we left there I went for about two
months I went to a startup called riot
dot-com and we took the Rubin report
there and at first for those of you that
never saw the Rubin report on The Young
Turks it was sort of a panel show I
would have three or four guests and it
was usually comedians and authors and it
was sort of like hot topics on the view
and and then we took the show after I
just I just didn't want to work at the
Young Turks anymore I just thought this
is not what I want to be part of and I
don't like what's happening here we took
it to riot riot it was a startup and we
thought the show was really gonna blow
up from there and then they started
going more into like 3d video and I
actually totally liked everybody there
and it was really cool place to work but
we did the show there for about two
months and we realized that just like
our futures were going in different
paths and that's when or a TV reached
out to me and or a TV you guys probably
know this was created by Larry King who
is my my friend and mentor and sort of
adopted extra grand father I suppose and
Larry King brought me into or a TV to do
a show and they built us a great set and
all that stuff and we were going to just
continue the Rueben report the same way
with the same panel show and the whole
thing and but the first episode and I
believed this was on September 9th of
2015 I had Sam Harris on and it was the
first time that I decided to do a
one-on-one interview because there was
so much happening with Sam he had been
lied about by so many people including
my former colleagues I saw the way the
left was trying to destroy a good
liberal who was just trying to talk
about some some difficult topics in an
honest way and I had Sam on and that was
when the second the show ended I thought
that was the most important thing that
I've ever done professionally and I
wanted that's the show I want to do I
want to do an interview show with
interesting thinkers and talk about
important things and not just talk about
clickbait and some of the nonsense that
we had sort of been taught at the Young
Turks that's what I wanted to do and we
stated a torah for about eight months
and that's when the show really blew up
i started talking about free speech more
but more than anything else I started
talking about my my frustrations with
the left as a liberal I started finding
other people who felt similar things
people who usually were good
old-fashioned
like Peter Bogosian and Maajid Nawaz and
ayaan Hirsi Ali and a whole slew of
people who were not far-right radicals
or anything who weren't even
conservatives who were just decent
people who were who were shocked by what
was happening with the progressives
which is so interesting because that was
that was literally four years ago I'm
talking about the fall of 2015 and I
started seeing this thing and talking
about it and suddenly people started
watching it's like everyone sees it now
like everyone sees how bananas the
progressives have gone now and the way
they've they've you know embraced
identity politics and the whole thing
anyway we stayed at aura for about eight
months and it was great there but we
were we were suddenly bigger than the
network and that is when in May or June
of 2016 I thought I thought we could do
this independently let's see if we could
do this independently and I was
basically the first one in the political
sphere to go on patreon and we left I
walked in to the to the greenroom and I
said to my producer and to my director I
said I'm leaving I hope you guys are
gonna join me and the three of us quit
our jobs full-time salaries health
insurance you know 401k is the whole
thing and we launched on patreon in May
or June of 2016 and the night before we
launched it was Sunday night I remember
I said to to David in amira I was like I
may have seriously screwed us like this
was before people were really
crowdfunding nobody really knew what
patreon was there were some video gamers
on there but nobody really in the
political or that I was like I may have
just totally just absolutely us I
have no idea what's gonna happen and we
woke up the next morning and within
about an hour I knew we were gonna be ok
and then we went completely independent
we then we've rented a studio some of
you may remember this I don't know that
I've actually ever said this publicly
but for about six months we rented a
studio which was actually owned here in
Los Angeles by Roseanne Barr who was a
friend of mine or is a friend of mine
and we rented a studio with her and that
was actually going great too
and then I realized well we're still not
totally independent right because I'm
crowdfunding on an off website that I
don't owned and I'm renting studio space
and then after about six months of that
or I don't even know it was six months
maybe about four months of that that's
when I decided all right I want a home
Stu
so that there is no more middleman and
real estate is not cheap here in LA I
had to take out two loans to do it just
for the down payment and everything else
but then we built this in November of
2016 and and then it was just a short
year later when all of this nonsense
happened with patreon and we decided to
build out Dave Rubin comm and Rubin
report calm and completely removed
patreon as the middleman and now I have
all of the tools to be totally free in
until today basically until we decided
to start locals calm and build our
community the one missing piece was we
had no way of getting directly in touch
with you we were still our way of
getting our content out there our way of
communicating directly with you still
had the big tech middleman and now we've
removed that we've removed that and not
only have we removed it I want all of
the lessons that I have learned for
these past couple years I want to kind
of pass these lessons on to all kinds of
creators so that you can be independent
- I really believe that independent
creators will save this you know why is
Hollywood so sucky right now why is
there so little good comedy anymore why
is there so so little good stuff it's
because everything comes from these big
mana lists and big corporations and all
this stuff and not that there's anything
inherently wrong with those things but I
don't think those things are made for
human ingenuity I think if we can give
the right tools to you guys out there
that are youtubers or you're musicians
or whatever you are and you can start
being funded by the people who support
you and you can start communicating with
them directly and and maybe meeting them
in real life and selling tickets through
what we do and doing more live events
and making sure that your content
actually gets to your people and again
if you want if you leave us it's yours
you could still contact them we're not
gonna own it we're not gonna well we're
not gonna exclusively own it to the
point where you can't have it I think
there's a lot of interesting things
happening here okay I want to thank
borealis Thomas Josh Christian LJ and
Nissan again anyone who downloads the
app from the Rubin Report app on the
Apple App Store or on Google Play I
think it's $9.99 on there I'm gonna sign
one of these we're gonna get this out to
you
immediately one of these pictures and
and just if you do it on Rueben report
calm it's just three bucks or more if
you do it there there's just a
difference in the way that Apple does
charging then then the website okay
let's see what else do we get if we join
the Reuben report community is the ad
free podcast part of it yeah so all of
our clips are on there right now every
every new clip that we've put up in the
last three months and eventually we're
gonna work on putting up all of our
archives on there all of our videos are
all they're completely ad free and I
think you're gonna be super impressed
with our video player by the way you
press the button and guess what the
video plays and it's pretty clean it's
pretty great
so the the ad free video is on there
there's ad free podcast on there
so I know look somebody some of you guys
just want to support right so there's a
lot of people actually that's support
and don't want anything they don't want
to be part of a community or they're
more private or they they don't even
care about ad free podcasts they don't
mind listening to ads any of those
things but if you support for as little
as 3 bucks not only will you get ad free
video and AD free podcast you will be
able to communicate with other fans
that's we're not really doing tiers at
the moment but if you want to
communicate with me directly
it's either 25 or 50 bucks you can
message me directly we're trying to
figure out all these things and we're
playing with all these things to figure
out what actually totally works right
but as I said we're also gonna have
group chat on there you'll be able to
buy tickets all of those things but more
than anything else you're supporting you
know these are sort of the bells and
whistles and I think building I think
building new mature communities that are
creator first instead of platform first
everything everything right now is
platform first and that's why they all
feel so crazy you've got all of these
people who all hate each other
attacking each other on all of these
platforms particularly Twitter but even
YouTube right like YouTube is designed
to make everybody crazy so every time
when when somebody starts doing
something good on YouTube what happens a
million lesser create or not lesser
create it's not exactly right way to say
it
but if you're doing something good on
YouTube what happens people start doing
all these videos about you because they
know that if someone puts your name in
the search bar because you're doing
something good or something popular well
they want to Jack that right so they go
out of their way to do videos to try to
take you
Wow like all of these games these
algorithmic games these search games
these recommended games I just don't
want to play these games anymore we're
gonna keep all of our stuff here we're
not going anywhere
right I mean maybe they'll kick me off
after this but we're not going anywhere
but what I really do believe is that the
future of this is no more games no more
games you you want to support people you
like you want to get things ad-free you
want to you want to communicate with
interesting people you want to not
infringe on anyone else's free speech
but you want to be in communities that
are of somewhat like-minded people and I
don't mean I don't mean politically
like-minded I mean people who basically
you know want to see the world in some
way that you kind of see it and that's
why you support certain creators well
then that's what we want to build for
you so so I'm excited about that so you
guys right now if you're a creator if
you're on I'm talking to all of you that
are on patreon right now there is no
more need to be on patreon patreon I'm
coming for you jack conte I'm sorry man
but this stuff doesn't fly anymore
nobody needs to be on these big
platforms if you're on patreon by the
way if you join locals you won't have to
cancel your patreon right away when we
when we moved over from patreon to Dave
Rubin com where we were just doing you
know our crowdfunding there when I left
patreon I I had done videos for a couple
weeks telling people I'm leaving patreon
on January 15th please cancel your
account and your support for me move
over to Dave Rubin comm support us
directly when I ended we still had about
10 grand a month sitting in there of
recurring payments and I guess I could
have just not cancelled my account and
just cashed in on that but obviously
that wouldn't have been ethical or
honest and I didn't want to do that but
if you're a creator on patreon right now
I know a lot of a lot of the fear around
moving to a new site or moving to a new
crowdfunding is that you're afraid it's
like oh well people support me on
patreon and I don't want to take the
risk of doing something else it's not
like we got to rip the band-aid off and
you're just canceling patreon and
joining us in one day you can do it take
as much time as you need to start
telling your patrons hey guys we've got
something better because I'm going to
own it you are going to own your
community and you can treat it however
you want to treat it I think that's a
great I think it's a great sell and your
people will come along
with you and over the course of a couple
weeks you can send out emails you can
post on patreon you can do live streams
whatever you got to do to tell them join
us over there and once you join us on
locals com
just cancel your patreon account and
we're here for you that's a that's a
pretty beautiful thing is the content
the same for all subscribers to the
Rubin report app or is some content
exclusive to a tier of premium
supporters I don't think we're gonna now
look first off every creator will be
able to do whatever they want again
you're setting the rules you want to
have tiered content that's premium at a
certain level of price you can do that
what we're gonna do is if you're in as
long as you're in at three dollars or
the minimum of three dollars and but
hopefully you want to put in more to
help support what we're doing
my feeling is I'm just gonna everything
that we put everywhere else we're gonna
put on the rubric or nap and we'll do
some premium stuff in that I'm gonna do
some more behind the scenes live streams
and so are some more personal stuff
we've got some interesting stuff maybe
with a book club and some dinner things
and some other live event things and a
little more impromptu stuff that that
the only way to really do that stuff
properly will be to do it through the
app I'm not gonna have a paywall like a
higher pay wall for extra content on the
Rubin Report app but again this is the
beauty of what we're building with
locals if another creator wants to have
totally different tiered access for
different things which is sort of a
little bit more of the patreon model go
ahead do it we can we can do that very
simply so I think right now the way you
can see that is that right now the only
thing that we're doing is that if you
want to message me directly if you go to
Rubin report comm right now and you sign
in there's a message Dave button if
you're only paying 3 bucks if you click
that button I think it says it's $25 or
something to message Dave directly by
the way I know it sounds sort of
ridiculous to do something like that but
imagine if I just left that up open I
would be getting hundreds or thousands
of messages every day so we have to have
some barrier to entry on that and
actually I think 25 is probably too
cheap not because not because of the
money but just because literally because
of my time more than anything else by
the way I also want to say that several
of the people that we've hired that are
building locals calm that are building
my app our fans so it's not just the
investors we've actually started a
really cool interesting worldwide there
are people all over the world that are
building this thing for us so and I
should give a
our team is absolutely incredible and
I've been working all hours of the day
and by the way we've we've started
showing locals calm around because
obviously we're gonna have to go in the
next round of fundraising now that I'm
now that I'm going public with this
right like we have we're gonna grow very
quickly right now we've been doing this
all on the on the DL on the back end and
we've been building out the way we
wanted to and it was a long time coming
to get to today and I hope you like our
branding and our graphics and all that
good stuff and the smoothness of the app
and everything else but now that we're
gonna go into fundraising we're gonna
weigh more eyeballs on us right now
and and things are gonna move pretty
quick and I hopefully will be able to
bring on as many creators as we can in
in short order so we'll see are you
going to continue posting on YouTube or
move your interviews to locals no
everything will remain on YouTube as
long as YouTube will have me but
remember this YouTube we shouldn't be
thinking of the big tech platforms as a
home or a community anyone out there
whatever you're creating these YouTube
is a search engine for video right
that's really what it is right they have
an algorithm and the algorithm when you
put in certain search terms can
manipulate things certain ways now I
don't want to get into all the details
of why they do it or how they do it or
whether it's being manipulated all that
although you may remember just a few
months ago a Google insider said that
one of the channels that was being
suppressed on YouTube was the Reuben
report Channel he also said Tim Poole
and a couple other people but none of us
should view big tech as our digital home
I want to create digital homes for
creators and by creating those digital
homes for creators we'll start creating
digital homes for you the consumers
because the creators will own what
they're doing they're gonna own their
websites right I own Rubin report comm
and the community there and the content
there and that way if YouTube wants to
suppress my videos I'm not demanding
that the government comes in and stop
them do I want a OC in bed with the
YouTube execs no I don't so so there's a
mature thoughtful way of dealing with
the future of the internet and then when
we have a lot of interesting creators
all who own their own content who own
their own communities who have decided
who they
a network with on the backend to create
bigger feeds and and bigger more robust
discussion well now we've got something
totally cool and it's a complete
everything we're doing with this
everything we're doing with this is a
complete flip on how big tech operates
on how this big business operates we're
really trying to give the power back to
the creators and give the power back to
you
- you guys Gracie I want to thank you
for signing up at $10 or above on
patreon we could talk to you directly
are you actually on the app in the
community yourself do you respond a lot
yes I do
I believe me this thing has been an
absolute pleasure I've responded to
people this morning already but when I
opened the app it is it is truly a
pleasure to go on there because there's
thoughtful interesting people who are
posting articles and asking questions
and commenting on things and talking
about what happened on the show last
week or what's going on in their lives
yes I'm going to spend way more of my
time on here then on the other social
media platforms I would rather invest in
the people who are investing in me then
invest in a bunch of anonymous trolls on
Twitter you know I mean we all know this
all of these things they're all making
us crazy and no one's doing anything
about it so that's why I wanted to start
doing anything about it
you look at the amount of blue check
people on Twitter who complain about
Twitter all day and yet we can't get off
because it's sort of like crack well I'm
not saying get off Twitter I'm not
saying get off YouTube stay on all of
those things you use them as you see fit
but why not have a special place a
special place for your community to be
able to talk to each other this is this
is the tab that I have open right now is
just the community tab where people are
posting shows that they're watching that
they find interesting or documentaries
or a restaurant that they went to all
sorts of different things that are all
on here and as I said we've got a great
video player so I posted I posted a
special message you see how fast that
work I just click Play and it worked
that was a special message I posted just
to our current subscribers this morning
telling them about what I'm what I'm
doing right now okay let's see how is
this different than patreon great
question which I've hit a couple times
patreon is a big tech platform you don't
own any of that stuff you post your
YouTube
it was there you post your ad free
podcast all of the data your customers
data your supporters that all that you
don't own any of that with locals you're
going to own it you are going to own it
you are going to set your rules
whatever rules you want for your
community are not going to be the
subjective manifest observable behavior
mob behavior that Jack Conte laid out to
me for patreon.com you will set the
rules for your community you will own
the content that you post there and you
will own the data so that if you're if
you want to leave us if you just want to
leave us you're just like you know what
this products not working or I don't
like the app or whatever it is I'm doing
I'm building my own thing
congratulations you can walk with all
that you can't walk with any of your
data from YouTube or patreon or the rest
of it again I have 1.2 million
subscribers on here I can't reach these
people because that's the system YouTube
has set so I've tried my best over the
last couple years to nudge YouTube in
the right way but I can't force YouTube
to do anything and I don't I certainly
don't want the government to force
YouTube to do anything so I thought all
right let me take control as much
control as possible and solve as many
problems that really was it more than
anything else I thought if I could solve
most of my problems as an independent
content creator then I could solve most
of the problems that most people have
and it's as simple as that and look if
you're if you're doing something that is
illegal well then we're not gonna have
you on locals calm obviously but short
of that if you're a creator building
something interesting and you have
people that want to support you you know
we're a tech company the way the way
that the way that Squarespace is a tech
company right
Squarespace isn't isn't monitoring
everybody that's on Squarespace all the
time you do whatever you want when you
build your website we want to build a
community for you it's it's you up to
you to set the rules that you want to
set I want to thank Richard Kelsey and
JC but Trago thank you very much
related question to communities versus
individual creators I've been
brainstorming a virtual art production
house where artists don't necessarily
all promote themselves but organize
through a virtual guild to promote their
collective arts any insight into a
single user can manage the local
interface as an administrator yeah I
mean I love that idea
so what you do is you try to get let's
say you let's say
in an artist community right now this is
a great example of how to how to use a
local and how we can build you something
really cool
so let's say you're in an artist
community there's like 15 you you all do
different interesting different things
some of you were into pottery some of
you were painters some of you were you
draw my hand some of you do 3d art
whatever it is somebody do glassblowing
whatever it is but you've got an
interesting community and you know that
none of you were huge yet right none of
you were absolutely huge where you could
own your own website where people would
want to pay in to see your stuff like
it's there's just not you haven't hit
that critical mass point right we've all
been there all of you creators watching
this right now like trust me I've been
there we've all been there well what you
could do is you could all decide well
we're gonna create a local together and
if if we can sort of join forces enough
to have enough people start supporting
us so let's say we each have we've all
got 10 super fans that love us but
that's not really enough reason to have
a community well now if we've got 12 of
us and we all have 10 super hands now we
have a hundred 20 people who all want to
pay you know 5 bucks a month and that
turns into we you know something like
600 bucks a month total we want to build
a community and then we want to start
inviting more people to be in this
community so there's all sorts of
interesting ways that these can work as
as collectives in the right sense of
collectivism dududu I'm on the thing
spot waitlist and therefore have no clue
what the site will entail that said what
if any will be the connection to locals
complimentary platforms competing
between similar platforms etc all right
so I'm glad you asked that and let me
let me address it straight on so first
off what first off I can't say too much
about Jordan but I just want you to know
that that Jordan Peterson is doing well
I saw him last week and he's gonna come
back bigger and better and stronger and
all of those things than ever before I
just have absolutely no doubt about that
and and I'm psyched for his for his
return so let me just say that we are
Jordan also knew all along you know back
in January when when Jordan and I left
patreon the idea of think spot came up
and I said to Jordan from day one I said
you know I've got this idea about an app
it's gonna think about these things a
little bit differently about behind
Jordan was all about it build it let's
build as many things as possible
no I'm gonna work on side things you
work on side things all of those things
so where I'm at right now is I'm putting
all of my energies into this into locos
comm I do think and I've communicated a
little bit with Jordans team but I can't
just say too much right now I hope and
think that there's ways we're gonna be
able to line these things up I don't
know exactly where the things about
launch is but Jordan has my has my
friendship and allegiance and all of
those things and if there's any way
which we can link these things up or if
I just can't even say too much more than
that but I do think that that solutions
are coming I think what we've built here
with locals comm is is probably the best
the best most most thoughtful way to
deal with the problems of the day right
we're all worried about being deep
platform well you're not going to be d
platformed off your own community we're
all worried about algorithms suppressing
videos and manipulating things we're all
worried about shadow banning this is why
if we can give the cut the the future is
the creators right the future is no
longer that networks nobody really care
like think about it when you flick a
channel anymore nobody really cares
about that or even think about like like
CNN or MSNBC or something like that it's
like nobody cares about these networks
anymore you might like one of the hosts
on these things but the the chair you
know it used to be that the chair had a
certain amount of value meaning like if
you had the 1130 chair on NBC in 1987
that was the Johnny Carson Tonight Show
and a certain amount of people were
gonna watch that whether Johnny was the
host or eventually whether it was Jay
Leno or whoever was meaning that the
chair itself was on at a certain time
and that was going to bring you a
certain amount of viewers I actually
don't think that's true anymore I think
what the truth is is that people care
about individual creators you care about
the people who are speaking to you
hopefully you're being forthright and
honest and decent and all that and those
are the people that I want to figure out
how we can help them build their
business you know what I mean like I
know a lot of people are a lot of people
are jealous jealous isn't the right word
there they're jealous in the in the best
sense of it of all of the things that
I've created and because of that I want
to give the tools ever every tool
I'm not used and and built to build all
of this I want to give to all the
creators that want to that want to do
that want to thank a sh real quick oh
how do we get one of these signed
pictures so if you want one of these
signed pictures I've got a fancy ultra
fancy pilot silver marker right here and
I'm signing headshots people for the
first hundred people that sign up at
$9.99 on the App Store for the Rubin
Report app or on Google Play we will
send you one of these I'm gonna sign it
right now this could be yours right
there or for as little as three dollars
on Ruben report comm and the reason that
we have to do that is just because of
the way the App Store deals with
financial transactions it just is what
it is we can't we can't we literally
can't charge you less than that it's a
long story
oh I should also mention that you know
part of what's going on here is that you
know there's this issue about
gatekeeping right like has Twitter and
YouTube and the rest of these big
companies have they become the
gatekeepers should we have gatekeepers
should everyone be allowed to be on
everything all of the time should there
be some limits on what is allowed in
public discourse and all that so without
getting into like the the purely
philosophical part of that which I talk
about all the time obviously right now
we can build you if we build you a
website there there's really no
gatekeepers we're a tech company we're
building you would get a website if
you're gonna be one of the premium gate
premium creators for us on locals calm
we're gonna build you an app that app is
gonna have to get into the App Store and
Google Play if those guys aren't gonna
let you in then there's some other
problems so and this is what I meant
about not trying to solve every problem
for every single person we're trying to
solve as many problems for as many
people as possible and I think by doing
that really starting with what I thought
were the issues for my business and how
I want to communicate with my audience
and how I want to engage with the people
who care about what I do I thought if we
if we solve that first that will solve
most people's problems we can't solve
everybody's problems it just is what it
is okay let's see very excited about
this in oak also locals calm as a
podcaster and someone with a very modest
group on Facebook these issues have been
at the forefront of my mind for the last
few months very excited to see all the
thank you Dave and the team well done
awesome look that's a beautiful thing I
was once but a humble modest podcaster -
you know you mean like really like
that's why I wanted to build this thing
I know there are so many great people
out there I you know I love competition
I really love competition and if there
were suddenly a hundred more interview
shows that did it better than I do it
right that built a better set and the
host was better and had better hair and
all of those things and better guests
and everything else either I would up my
game or I'll find something else out
I'll find something else to do okay so I
really want to give you guys the power
not to be beholden to these things the
amount of people that I know good people
who have been on this show who have been
banned or temporarily suspended from
Facebook for saying nothing you know
saying true things about genders or just
any of this nonsense we're constantly
being force-fed right now and that that
was another reason you know a couple
months ago when when Zuckerberg was up
in front of Capitol Hill and they kept
saying that you know he kept saying well
we can't scan every ad to figure out if
it's fully true we just can't do that we
want we want the market to figure that
out we want people to figure out on
themselves and aoc and the rest of them
are sort of playing bass ting him for
this and it's like all right so what are
you really saying because if you're
saying that we want Facebook to say what
is true well if you were to ask a
higher-up at Facebook how many genders
there are now we know there are two
genders that doesn't mean you shouldn't
be disrespectful of of trans people
trans people I think deserve the exact
same respect and certainly equal
treatment under the law of everybody
else but that doesn't change what
biology is right but if you were to say
there are two genders that could be
considered hate speech potentially by
Facebook's Terms of Service or youtubes
or whatever else so these things these
this competing set of interests where we
demand that someone who has more power
than us they tell us what is true I just
I just think it's nonsense I don't think
it's the future of any of this what I
think the future of this is is that
little communities will grow and as they
grow they will find other communities
that they want to connect to it that are
somewhat like mine that are totally
like-minded are very different but can
figure out some
thing that they agree upon so that
communities from one creator and
communities from another creator can
start communicating themselves and they
can do this through their own desktop
apps or web-based or native apps on
iPhones and androids and the rest of it
and that will be the future small is the
new big I really believe it I really
believe it it's the only way to solve
some of these problems and I know that
obviously when I sign off this thing
I'll be getting a ton of hate on Twitter
and oh my god he's charging and uh and
it's like alright if you don't want to
be part of it and you don't have to be
part of it and by the way if if you want
to pay me if you want to pay me to troll
me or say awful stuff or fight with
people or the rest of it I may tolerate
a little of that just because I'm a
pretty tolerant guy but but ultimately
we'll just boot you and refund your
money I don't I don't want your money
I'm trying to I'm trying to build
something for mature people I'm trying
to build something for people that want
to build and not burn everybody wants to
burn everything down these days right
that seems to be the theme almost
everywhere and it's not just in America
there's this theme of just like let's
destroy the whole thing I'm not
interested in that I'm interested in
building sort of sustainable long
lasting things as we watch the as we
watch the institutions of old crumble
and we're watching them right we're
watching the institution of television
and media crumble were watching
financial institutions crumble we're
watching academic institutions crumble
let's start building new institutions I
think this is my first foray at it and
and we're gonna give it a shot where do
you see locals one year from now I mean
we've got big plans which I can't I
can't tell you all of it but I might
hope with locals one year from now is
that we have taken as many content
creators out there we've we've gotten
you know hopefully thousands of people
off patreon at that point or however
else they're funding we've shown enough
people that you shouldn't just be
reliant on big tech you shouldn't leave
your future up to YouTube's the
algorithm to decide whether you're
successful or not and how that should
affect your your financial stability and
the rest of it we've created small
communities that have connected with
other committees to start building all
new networks I mean really new networks
of creators and just wait over the next
couple weeks as we lay out
some of the people that I'm bringing on
board this that I'm going to network
with thus creating our networks and then
I think we'll have all of these new
networks and then maybe we start
figuring out some new things related to
advertisers or a whole bunch of other
things I think the the futures are
always straight that's why I wanted to
build this thing
and own it and own it so I could so I
could hear what the concerns are from
you guys I could look at my own business
and go well what are what are my
concerns and then we could we could kind
of go from there so that so I think I
think this thing's going to be huge this
is my best effort guys this is
absolutely my best effort and I think
we've built the right team I think we
have the right investors we've got the
right developers oh by the way I should
have told you this right at the
beginning we're hiring also right we've
got a pretty great company here if you
are a developer and app guy you're in
Data any of these thing graphics
whatever you think if you dig any of the
things that I have talked about right
here
email us jobs at locals comm we're
hiring we're hiring so email us at jobs
dot jobs at locos comm and let's figure
I mean this is what community is all
about right if you dig what I'm talking
about wouldn't it be cool to to help us
build something that could be internet
3.0 that could be the future of all this
stuff I think that would be pretty
freakin awesome and I'm seriously
excited about it we're also looking for
investors so you can email us just email
contact at Rubin report com
I look I've gotten friends in big tech
and I've talked to some people and there
might be some interesting plays with
that but I love that we've built this so
far with just a couple individuals who
are taking a chance just taking a chance
and who are mission aligned and believe
in what we're doing so I'm excited about
that
if locals creates an app for me well I
have community building and tech support
from anyone okay so one of the other
things is we're gonna help you guys on
the back end you know one of the things
that I hear all the time is that all
these creators you get on patreon you
start getting success and then what
happens is doing all of the things to
communicate with your fans and to do all
the rewards and to moderate content if
that's what you want to do all of these
things become other jobs and then before
you know it you're succeeding except
your ability to create is actually
diminishing the
you're doing all the business stuff that
you don't want to do so yes we want to
be the business behind you we want to be
the business behind you we want to help
you manage your subscribers communicate
with people newsletters all of those
things basically if you're a creator we
want to give you the tools to create and
we'll handle as much of the rest of the
stuff as possible so it starts with will
build your desktop community and if
you're if you're at a level enough where
it financially makes sense we're gonna
build you a native white labeled app
it's pretty awesome I assure you and and
then we go from there and we're gonna
help you be able to focus on what you
want to focus on which usually is just
creating content and not having to deal
with all the stuff on the back end by
the way as I said because you're setting
your own rules in your community if you
want more moderation in the comments so
let's say you know you have a totally
your policy is you know I don't want
people talking about this or that I
don't want people promoting themselves
or bah-bah-bah
well we'll handle some of that
moderation but again it will be up to
you in your community so this isn't a
platform wide thing the day of platform
wide rules that apply to everybody seems
very silly and archaic to me so that's
what we're gonna do is there a space for
small local businesses I create custom
wooden baseball bats for all levels of
play and ages my intention is to is to
be and stay local which means I would
remain relatively small but I would love
to support it be a part of it so I love
that so that's that's really the next
part of this that I that I really want
to figure out we've been talking about
you know a lot of what I'm framing here
is for content creators right like it's
for people that create video and audio
podcast and the rest of it but I
mentioned before it's funny to say
baseball bats because I mentioned
because I have a friend who runs a
baseball league back east and he's got
you know a couple hundred families that
are really engaged in local baseball and
it's like they also want to support the
local team and local communities so I
think we're gonna start working with him
where everyone just puts in a couple
bucks a month that money then can be
used to clean up fields or buy uniforms
or whatever it is we will help manage
the community and and you can use this
platform for whatever you want so yeah I
want businesses on there so so for
someone like you let's say you're
creating great great wood in baseball
bats you want to stay local in your
community what you have to figure out is
why would say a fan of what you do give
you a couple bucks a month so it's worth
having your own community and then are
there other like-minded communities that
you want to connect with that or maybe
in the baseball world or the sports
world or the woodworking world or
whatever it is that you can connect with
so you guys can all sort of network
together and a little bit of this is
gonna be a learning process and I and I
hope that if you if you join us on here
and it's worthwhile for you and let's
say you've got you know a couple hundred
or a thousand people who really dig what
you do and they want to just help
support your business with a couple
bucks a month and then start engaging a
little bit more on their that then the
answers will start presenting themselves
I'm a big believer that if you build it
they will come so we'll figure out as
much of this stuff as possible okay
people I'm gonna do a little radio reset
here what have I been babbling about for
the last hour and a half look we we all
know about big tech problems we know
about shadow banning we know about
algorithmic manipulation we know about D
boosting and D platforming well
everybody's been complaining about it
and everybody's demanding the government
do it or that Twitter's start behaving
better than they will or any of those
things you've watched Jack Dorsey on
Rogen and gave us no answers I've had
jack conte from Twitter from patreon on
here apparently it's a Jack thing to run
one of these companies I thought over
the last year there has to be a better
way to do this and my feeling was as
small as the new big that actually
having people put a little skin in the
game pay a couple bucks a month to
support creators that they want to just
the way you you buy in you pay a couple
bucks a month for Netflix or for Disney
Plus or for Hulu or whatever else you do
you know the day of the bundled package
where you know you're your parents
probably we're paying 120 bucks a month
to have a gajillion channels that they
don't watch is over cancel cable and
start paying for for people and projects
that you actually like and want to
support and if we can start creating
small local networks who can network
with other people that that is the
future of the bottom-up Internet that is
the future of that is that as in sir
at 3.0 that's the way we get the power
back to the creators that's the way we
make sure that we're fighting the
machines properly right like think about
it in a terminus Terminator sense Skynet
is on right now right the machines are
coming the algorithms are coming the way
they can manipulate us in search results
and all those things it's all here it's
all here so the only way I wasn't gonna
demand the government fix my problem is
if the government which you know you
look at a government website it looks
like prodigy in nineteen you know 92 as
if the government was gonna solve big
tech issues I just don't believe it so
what what do I think is actually
possible well what I think is possible
is exactly what we created here we can
build you a great community website
where your fans can connect with you
where you can monetize where you can
have video and audio and chat and we're
gonna eventually have live streaming and
group chat and a whole bunch of other
things and then you'll associate with
other creators you want to thus creating
a network effect we'll think of networks
in a new way instead of thinking about
big networks with huge overhead and all
of those things independent content
creators will start having their own
networks I think as I said before I
think it solves as many of the big tech
problems as can possibly be solved I
don't think the answer is just creating
some another free site that says we will
respect free speech more than the next
guy plenty of people have tried that by
the way and what happens is only a
certain set of people go there then
mainstream media tries to destroy them
and then they just can't they can't get
to scalability so I just didn't want to
do that I this is every single thing
that we've laid out here with locals
calm is completely consistent with all
of the ideas that I that I believe in
and try to talk about on this show we've
ran a test for the last two months by
creating the Reuben report calm
community first with just a couple dozen
people and now getting a few more people
in there and it's starting to percolate
it's starting to bubble and I hope that
I will see more of you guys in there and
that's where I'm gonna communicate with
you and I'll start telling you where I'm
doing live events or just impromptu show
ups and you can buy tickets to things
and make sure that you actually see our
videos instead of being reliant on big
tech but we don't know what the hell
they're doing
I just believe it can be done and as I
said before if David could beat Goliath
then maybe Dave could be Google we shall
see I want to thank memes Jane
David Michael and okay I think we're
gonna we're gonna stop in just a little
bit so wait so I got I got 100 I got
papers here I got pictures here all
sorts of things so for the last few
people that want to sign up while we're
doing this live stream I will sign one
of these bad boys for you so if you go
to the iTunes App Store or the Apple App
Store you go to Google Play $9.99 a
month to sign up for the Reuben Report
app the app itself is free but if you
want to engage in the content in any
sort of meaningful way you got to pay I
really believe that is the future of the
new Internet that that is it and I think
people are willing to do it and
sometimes you have to kind of train
people we're gonna have we're gonna
better more mature gated communities not
because we're infringing on anyone's
rights but because we want to protect
people's rights and we want to sort of
protect people's ability to to share
things without fear of being destroyed
and mobbed and taken out by anonymous
accounts and bots so if you're a hater
if you're one of the premier Dave Rubin
haters you could try to sign up right
now you could try to sign up right now
and jump in there and hate me all you
want I'll either I'll either take your
money and then you have to grapple with
that and grow this show and all of the
ideas that I'm talking about even bigger
or or were just gonna boot yeah and
that's not deep platforming you because
it's not a worldwide platform right
we're creating small communities for
creators and then as we do that those
creators will network with each other
and then we will build something big
bottom up if you build it they will come
that's what I believe so you can go
right now to Rubin report calm and you
can be part of our community and for as
little as $3 although if you do over $10
we're gonna send you one of these as
long as you do it while we're doing this
live stream and more importantly the
business behind this is locals calm I
have I have one business partner I have
three investors I am taking no salary
from this thing I obviously own a
portion of it and we and we hope it will
be will be far bigger than anything else
I've done I really think there's a
chance but this is my best effort to
solve as many of the problems as
possible with the internet and and
hopefully give the power back to you
guys
nobody's doing anything right like no
everyone's complaining about everything
everyone's asking
somebody else do it you ever see that
episode of The Simpsons where everyone
in Springfield once can't somebody else
do it but you're somebody else too
loosely quote Homer from another episode
I'm a guy like me and I thought all
right maybe I can solve some of this
stuff so I think I really think we have
we can protect your digital assets we
can help you grow your business we can
help you communicate with your fans we
can make sure that if you have a support
base that they're gonna actually see
your content and it's not going to be
manipulated in any way we're gonna make
sure that we're not selling your data
and if and if you leave by the way if
you leave locals calm we're gonna delete
all your all your info we'll keep your
your screen names so that in case you
want to come back but beyond that we're
deleting all the stuff we're never gonna
be in the business of selling data and
if you as a creator leave locals
congratulations you can keep all of your
your supporters email addresses and the
rest of it so you can contact them right
now I mean really think about it think
about it right now I give one of the
most professional shows there is on
YouTube out of the hundreds of thousands
or millions of channels that there are
it's got to be millions at this point on
YouTube I give them one of the most
professional shows there are four four
plus years I didn't even have a contact
at YouTube now I do have a contact she
seems actually quite lovely I think
she's coming here tomorrow for lunch but
I have no way of communicating with my
audience here on YouTube only a certain
set amount of people got to see this
live stream right now and once the live
stream is over and we post the video
only a certain set amount of people get
it they don't they make sure that your
videos don't get out to all of your
people
even the people who want to see your
videos who subscribe to your videos and
then they do all sorts of things related
to recommended videos where they push
you away from certain channels and push
you towards certain channels I tried to
fight that as much as I could and and I
suppose at certain level there certainly
within their right to do it but I
thought there's got to be a better way
to do this and I think we can do
something really cool in them and I'm
excited about it so if you're a creator
guys go to locals calm this is just the
beginning sign up tell us how many
people you've got supporting you what
you're trying to build we'll be reaching
out to people over the next couple weeks
we've already got a couple very cool
creators who I know most of you guys
know that are gonna be on board this
thing and I'll be networking with them
and seeing what we can build out of that
so I'm super psyched about that
but if you're a creator go to logos comm
tell us a little bit about yourself
let's see if we can give you as many of
the tools that I've built here so that
you can be as free as possible because
because you will own your community that
is completely different than anything
that's happening elsewhere and and I'm
very excited about that
I want to thank Louisa real quick and
and one more time Ruben report comm if
you want to be part of our community and
and locals calm if you want to be part
of your community obviously this is just
the beginning
if you want to work for us if you've got
any tech experience graphic designers
developers architects whatever it is
jobs at locals calm and if you're
interested in investing and again I'm
not taking any salary from this thing if
you're interested in investing you can
email us at contact at Ruben report comm
it's my best effort to try to do
something I think it's gonna work I
really believe it's gonna work I
wouldn't have done it if I didn't think
so otherwise everyone that we have shown
this to and we you know we've gone into
some some pretty influential big
businesses over the last couple weeks
and we've had to sign a lot of MBAs to
to make sure people aren't leaking it
and the rest of it we have blown away
people we have blown away people with
what we've built here so I'm super
psyched and here we go again I always
say it's funny for all the things that I
build and all the times I've changed
networks or built a home suit or all
these things it's like I'm always back
at the beginning and I think today is
another day that I'm kind of back at the
beginning but I'm psyched to be doing
this with you guys and I appreciate all
of your support whether it's just
watching the videos whether it's
emailing me whether whether you actually
support us on Ruben report.com
or or financially or whether whether you
used to support us on patreon or
whatever else it is I think this is the
best shot we got i fixing some of these
some of these problems and i hope you'll
be part of it whether as a supporter or
someone who just watches these videos
and shares them or whether who's someone
who ends up working for us that's jobs
at locals calm or as a creator who wants
to take the power back to themselves
that's what this really is about and if
you want to build out your community and
make sure your assets are yours and your
digital future is yours and not be
relying on big tech we're here for you
locals calm I'm Dave Rubin of the room
Report signing out